en los vídeos anteriores hablamos sobre
reflexión
qué es el concepto de que los rayos de
luz van a rebotar en una superficie si
la superficie es suave o lisa como esta
cuando un rayo de luz caiga sobre ella
así
el ángulo de incidencia o el ángulo con
el que cae este rayo va a ser el mismo
con el que va a rebotar
y estos ángulos se van a medir con
respecto a la vertical a una
perpendicular a la superficie y este
ángulo será el ángulo de incidencia y
este ángulo será el ángulo de reflexión
y va a ser igual al ángulo de incidencia
esto en esencia es lo que aprendimos en
los vídeos anteriores lo que quiero
explicar en este vídeo es cuando la luz
no rebota en la superficie sino que
entra o pasa a otro medio en esta
situación trabajaremos con la refracción
y fracción
refracción
en donde tenemos la luz que llega a una
interfase entre dos medios voy a dibujar
esta va a ser la interfase esta
perpendicular
y digamos que aquí vamos a tener un rayo
de luz
más o menos así que va a llegar con
cierto ángulo 1 con respecto a esta
vertical de está 1
pero lo que sucederá es que bueno
digamos que aquí lo que tenemos arriba
es vacío
lo que tenemos aquí abajo va a ser
aunque esto no es algo que encontremos
en la naturaleza porque al haber aquí un
vacío no va a haber presión que mantenga
el agua en un lugar y va a hacer que el
agua se evapore entonces nunca vamos a
tener el agua directamente en contacto
con el vacío pero bueno sigamos con el
problema con este ejemplo
lo que va a pasar cuando llegue el rayo
acá es que al llegar a este otro medio
que va a ser más lento la velocidad de
la luz al entrar en el agua de lo que es
cuando está en el vacío entonces lo que
va a suceder es que el rayo de luz va a
cambiar de dirección al entrar a este
otro medio va a doblarse un poco así y
este ángulo de acá que se forma entre la
vertical y este rayo que ya entró de
este otro medio se llama theta 2 y es el
ángulo de refracción de hasta 1 es el
ángulo de incidencia y 30 2 es el ángulo
de reflexión y antes de que le diga cómo
estos dos ángulos se relacionan entre sí
y cómo se relacionan con la velocidad de
la luz y el medio nuevamente les
recuerdo que nunca podemos tener estos
dos elementos el agua y el vacío
tocándose entre sí ya que por falta de
presión el agua se evapora y antes
entrar a la matemática propiamente
quiero darles un entendimiento de qué es
lo que sucede aquí
necesariamente explicarles cómo funciona
la luz ya que veremos en futuros vídeos
que la luz no es algo fácil de
comprender pues a veces la tratamos como
una onda a veces como una partícula
otras veces como un fotón pero cuando
hablamos de la refracción a mí en lo
personal me gusta imaginar que la luz es
como un vehículo por ejemplo imaginemos
que tengo aquí un auto que vamos a estar
viendo por encima o desde arriba aquí es
donde están los pasajeros aquí están las
llantas sus cuatro llantas
imaginamos que este auto está en una
carretera en donde las llantas pues
tienen buena fracción carretera y el
auto se va a mover de manera eficiente
pero imaginemos que va a estar a punto
de entrar en una zona donde hay luz esto
de aquí es los entonces el auto pues va
a seguir con su dirección pero qué va a
pasar justo en el momento en el que
comienza a entrar en esta zona de lodo
bueno
pues las llantas en el lodo no se van a
mover bien imaginemos que tenemos el
auto justo aquí más o menos
está en los pasajeros aquí una llanta ya
entró al lodo y las otras dos llantas
solado este lado nuestro lado derecho
sigue en la carretera por lo que esta
llanta de acá este de que iba a comenzar
a ir despacio se va a empezar a alentar
porque ya está en el lodo mientras que
estas otras van a seguir con la
velocidad que llevaban con el
comportamiento que traían y el resultado
es que esto al entrar en el lodo va a
empezar
a girar hacia acá entonces el lugar
siguiese moviendo derecho el auto va a
comenzar a tener otra dirección
obviamente la luz no tiene ruedas ni
interactúa con el lodo pero es la misma
idea general cuando viaja de un medio
más rápido a un medio más lento casi
pueden imaginar las ruedas de esa luz en
este lado del vacío justo cuando ésta
llega al nuevo medio en donde irá más
lento y girará un poco de derecha a
izquierda lo mismo ocurre al revés si yo
tengo un rayo que sale de este medio
lento más o menos por aquí que está mi
rayo que va saliendo
si usamos la misma analogía del auto en
esta situación el lado izquierdo del
auto imaginemos aquí este como el auto
va a llegar primero al área donde se
mueve más rápido por lo que va a empezar
a girar ya que esto todavía sigue en la
parte lenta va a empezar a girar aquí y
entonces el rayo de luz se va a doblar
así
espero que esto les haya dado una
intuición sobre cuál lado es el que se
va a doblar o inclinar un rayo de luz al
entrar o salir de un medio más rápido a
uno más lento y ya que hemos comprendido
esto les platico que existe algo llamado
ley de snl
de snl
y para explicar de lo que se trata esta
ley voy a agregar aquí las velocidades
velocidad 1 para el rayo que viene aquí
en este medio y velocidad 2 para el rayo
que está la velocidad que tiene el rayo
aquí en este otro medio aunque saben que
mejor vamos a redibujar de nuevo ese
diagrama y aprovecho para quitar este
ejemplo del agua con el vacío que
realmente no me convence porque esto no
puede existir en la naturaleza
dibujamos nuestro nuevo diagrama por acá
dibujamos la vertical así
y ahora en lugar de tener agua voy a
tener aquí vidrio y aquí si podemos
tener vidrio
junto al vacío
el rayo en el vacío va a viajar
con una velocidad de 1
de hecho la luz alcanza su máxima
velocidad estando en el vacío la
velocidad de la luz la vamos a escribir
así se denota por la letra c y es
aproximadamente igual a 300.000
kilómetros por segundo es un valor
aproximado no sé poniendo la cantidad
exacta y aquí escribo que se es la
velocidad
de la luz
vacío
y me refiero al vacío como un espacio
que no tiene nada en él ni gana ni
moléculas absolutamente nada por lo que
en el vacío la luz va a estar viajando
con mucha velocidad y digamos que por
cierto esto va a aplicar para dos medios
cualquiera
este rayo de luz va a llegar al vidrio
en donde va a viajar más lentamente este
lado del auto si retomamos la analogía
del auto que vimos hace un momento va a
viajar más lentamente esto que está
tocando el vidrio y comenzará a girar un
poco de manera que el rayo se va a
doblar y va a cambiar su ángulo así más
o menos y de hecho a esta velocidad le
llamamos b2 y es más lento que como
viajaba antes con respecto a b1 y si
estos son vectores pues vamos a cortar
este ya que va a viajar más lentamente
ok aquí está nuestro rayo con la
velocidad 2 el ángulo de incidencia este
de acá le llamamos teta 1 y el ángulo
con el que se refleja o con el que se
cambia el rayo al llegar a este segundo
medio va a ser teta dos de está uno es
el ángulo de incidencia de todos es el
ángulo de refracción
snail no dice que la nación o proporción
entre velocidad 2 y el seno del ángulo
de refracción vamos a escribirlo acá la
velocidad 2 entre el seno del ángulo de
refracción que es de todos va a ser
igual a la razón de la velocidad 1 entre
el seno del ángulo de incidencia que
éste está 1 sé que esto puede sonar
confuso y vamos a aplicar esta fórmula
en los siguientes vídeos pero quiero
mostrarles que hay muchas formas de
representar esta ley de snail quizás
ustedes estén o no familiarizados con el
concepto de índice de refracción vamos a
escribirlo
índice
índice d
fraction
y cada material tiene su índice de
refracción de hecho aquí les puedo
mostrar
con una imagen que tiene una tablita del
índice de refracción tenemos el índice
de refracción del vacío tenemos también
del aire del agua aceite etcétera el
inicio de refracción se denota con la
letra n
y se define como que n va a ser igual a
la velocidad de la luz en el vacío entre
la velocidad que alcanza la luz en el
medio al que corresponde este índice de
refracción en nuestro ejemplo podemos
sustituir esta ley de snl y dejarla en
términos del índice de refracción que es
una de las maneras típicas en las que
podemos ver esta fórmula de la ley de
snl voy a despejar ve de aquí me
interesa la velocidad que es lo que voy
a sustituir en esta fórmula por lo que
voy a multiplicar ambos lados de la
ecuación por b me quedaba por n igual a
c / b por b se cancela en estos 2
y ahora voy a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre n me queda de x n entre n
es igual a c entre n estos dos se van de
manera que la velocidad en términos del
índice de refracción me va a quedar que
es igual a la velocidad de la luz entre
el índice de refracción y ahora vamos a
sustituir estas velocidades en esta
fórmula por lo que velocidad 2 va a ser
igual a la velocidad de la luz entre el
índice de refracción de este material 2
n 2 todo esto que es la velocidad 2 va a
estar dividido entre el seno del ángulo
de refracción que es de todos y esto va
a ser igual a la velocidad de la luz
entre el índice de reflexión del primer
material dividido todo entre el seno del
ángulo de incidencia o el teta 1 vamos a
simplificar esto voy a sacar los
recíprocos en ambos lados de la ecuación
de manera que me va a quedar la fórmula
seno de 30 2
entre la velocidad de la luz entre el
índice de refracción 2 que es igual al
seno de teta 1 entre la velocidad de la
luz dividida entre el índice de
refracción 1
voy a multiplicar el lado izquierdo por
n 2 / n 2 aquí no estoy cambiando nada
esto es realmente un 1 pero al hacer
esto esté n 2 se va a ir con esta otra n
2 lo mismo hago de este otro lado ahora
multiplicó y vivido este término por n 1
/ n 1 y estos dos elementos
se van a ir y me va a quedar la fórmula
n 2
por el seno de teta 2 / c igual a seno
detecta uno por n 1 en 13 y estos dos
elementos los puedo quitar de acá
de manera que la fórmula me va a quedar
n 2 el índice de refracción 2 por el
seno del ángulo teta dos igual a n 1 por
el seno del ángulo teta 1 esta es la
fórmula de la ley de snail pero en
términos de los índices de refracción la
quitamos de aquí
pegamos y ahora la vamos a colocar
de manera que tengamos las dos fórmulas
más comunes para expresar la ley de
snail juntas aplicaremos esto en los
siguientes vídeos por lo que quiero
asegurarme de que se sientan cómodos con
esto y sepan que ambas fórmulas son
equivalentes de la ley de snl una trata
con las velocidades directamente en
relación con los ángulos incidente y de
refracción y en esta otra se usan los
índices de refracción en donde este
índice es la velocidad de la luz / la
velocidad de la luz en el medio en
aquellos medios en donde la velocidad de
la luz a través de ellos sea más lenta
está n va a ser mayor ya que la
velocidad de la luz en el vacío que es
esta se va a ser más grande que el valor
de la velocidad en el medio aquí les
muestro nuevamente la tablita que tiene
los valores de los índices de refracción
y por ejemplo podemos ver que el valor
el índice de refracción en el vacío es 1
lo que es lógico ya que es aquí
el indicio de refracción va a ser igual
a la velocidad de la luz como está
definido / pues la velocidad en el vacío
es la velocidad de la luz así que esto
es un 1 podemos ver que el inicio de
refracción del aire es un poquito más
grande que en el vacío sin embargo los
índices de refracción en el agua o en el
aceite pues van siendo cada vez más
grandes porque la diferencia entre la
velocidad de la luz en el vacío y la
velocidad de la luz en el medio va a ser
mayor la velocidad en el medio va a ser
más lento en los próximos vídeos haremos
más ejemplos usando la ley de snail y en
el siguiente vídeo usaré esta imagen
para ayudar a explicar por qué es que
vemos esta imagen doblada de este popote
que está entrando acá